[музика]
борошно
їжею чебан так часто називають єдину
державу інший пишу слухаю че не знали
значну компанію відвідали тим україном і
курсу валу коней та червона били втрати
20 уроків тому ринок відкрився для
правота пореві знаки на кольє вийшов і
ознакою львові по їзди та шик компанії
вишес приватних компанії обслуга почувши
за низьких маршрутів чуїв вже прийдуть до
вам сектором на ринку перевезено
найбільшої обидві кішки у припадаючи на
регіональні втрати з близько 9,6
мільярдів євро нарік за шмот активатор
туба копання компанія томасу герцена
kellys дойчланд
данина французької корпорації широкого
на привозить на 30 мільйонів
пасажирів
у землі та зовнішньої рейн-вестфалія ще на
на заході не міченим тут терикона них
приватні ознаки травня but i wish i він з
україна щепотин та знаєш нас учасники
ніш тримаючи поза на регіональних маршрутах
їм середньому честь висимо рокки у точно
сніг державним часто по 20-30 рокер
у нас є кондиціонери упа тягах з
учасник інформації не табло і ми підтиснули
і встановлювати і вайфай і на adsense у
не мечі не шкірна 16 федеральних земель
сама проводить тендер і сир та внутрішніх
прив'язних you та укладаю я контракти на
десять-п'ятнадцять rock you then on apr
миски з отриманням такої встановленої
місце влада 1 туві для всіх ще компасу
ватів витрати компаній широкий з
федерального бюджету gem виділяти над
7 мільярдів євро
сама за декаду to them by 6 право тієї
компанії наша старту вати на
регіональному рівні
ринок перевезений на інший
станьте їм поки не замах необхідно
ти навіть дорогий рукам і склад які
ніхто не може і біду золото атаку чекають
ремонту норми права лайки просто
неймовірно складні сама тому дойче бан
майдас і 99 сотки на ринку зручних
перевезень шанс на регіональному рівні
дочка u-bahn також лідируємо зараз q85
500 київ
наріж 125 високих припадаючи кілька сад
приватних компаній монополію дочка
ебануло кпс немає і чи винна чума
перевали
у його пит порядку ванні даси прибуває
Станьте і коли шлях їм начхати не
ознаки
ви знаєте хлопець про наше європейське
україни ми регіональні за різний
ринок не матч і нік абсолютно вигляд критий
ту модель он і народися прийняті українці